today's guest is undefeated in the MMA
fighting he is a one-of-a-kind type of
sensation he's here with his coach Tim
Welch who you'll also hear on the mic in
the back it's it's exciting to sit down
with him the sugar show himself mr. Sean
O'Malley
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah but it started for us is happy now
you know I was a big Dustin Poirier fan
I still Emily doesn't play and so he
like he was like the first like dream
guest we ever had I was like dude what
if we could get Dustin Poirier on and
like so then went eventually he came in
and so then that's how slowly even
started getting into UFC and then Rogan
knew I was a fan and so he took me to
win Dustin and max Holloway fought it
was a you're there live yeah bro ever
been to yeah who's the co-main remember
Israel and Gastelum that might be one of
the sickest fight ever
but Dustin burrs max might be up there
too oh it was crazy man and I was like
bro I don't even like I don't even know
what happened to me I turn like
something came out of me I think this
inner part of me that always had been
like afraid to fight just came out of me
as like a fan and so then slowly I've
like really started to get into the
sport more to you know it's a [ __ ]
crazy sport did I used to be afraid to
watch it dude I literally told on my dad
because my mom was white or my I told on
my dad told my mom because my dad is
watching I was probably 13 14 and I like
it was a bad thing I'm like wow I
thought it was [ __ ] up yeah how do
they take those shots to the rib
you're like mom dad look what dad's
doing I'm like dad watch out cuz I
wanted to watch them and I was like
literally disgusted by eating and stuff
I'm just like this skinny little [ __ ]
kid never thought about fighting at all
were you um what are your parents are we
going yeah oh good what are your uh what
are your parents do my mom she's retired
basically now but she was a nurse and my
dad is a detective know so i growing up
was terrified of marijuana and we lived
in helena montana tiny [ __ ] place
yeah and so if anybody was smoking weed
i looked at it like they were doing meth
in my head right like I was like
associating it with the same same stuff
yeah plant so so that my dad was
detected obviously [ __ ] love
marijuana now but it was crazy cuz I
just looked at it so bad no when I moved
to Phoenix it kind of like seems like
come on try it right so I tried it I'm
like
your coach yeah coach coach you in the
back but it was because he thought it
would be good for me cuz I'm a [ __ ]
spaz everyone 10 p.m. we trained twice
five hours and I was like let's go do
something hard he's like the [ __ ] up
take a hit I would just take him oh
that's pretty nice be able to chill for
a little bit so uh yeah my dad's a
detective he's retired now - he does
something I'm not sure what the [ __ ] he
does now but did he ever do any murders
and stuff like that even he he did it
yeah he did he was in the for about 20
20 years and he told me some [ __ ] up
stories well love murder bro murdered
like this guy got he was in a helicopter
and my dad was like him first on the
scene he like completely was splattered
all over the dash of the helicopter cuz
it ran into a mountain or some [ __ ] but
he would tell me some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
about like him having to interview guys
that were raping their daughters that
were in wheelchairs oh and that's the
[ __ ] that he was like I [ __ ] hate
this job that's too much that's too much
and then and that wasn't just like one
time that's like numerous times just
having a bad face the devil like that
yeah you're looking right at that when
you talking to something like that
you're looking at the devil yeah sitting
there having those conversations and
then you and then think like after that
conversations later that day you're
probably running it through your mind
and thinking about like what the [ __ ]
there's people like this yeah sad ooh
and you see your mom was a nurse that's
a really loving job I feel like you have
to be it takes a special type of person
to be a nurse yeah she was she was super
like caring and loving towards growing
up we had three there was three boys and
then my sister so yeah it was she was
super caring and loving she still is she
still treats me like I'm [ __ ] six
yeah because the other day like she
still sees me in a certain way which is
really weird because I moved to Phoenix
about six years ago and she still looks
at me as I come on that little SH I'm
her Shaunie a little boy because she I
told her don't watch any of my podcasts
don't watch any of my vlogs and she
watched our blast vog road to USA 250 it
was like we put it out it was before I
got the call to fight Eddie and
that in the beginning episode as Tim was
pretending to stand up and give $50,000
stimulus check to everybody and I went
die [ __ ] and my mom watched the
beginning of that she called me crying I
didn't raise you like that that's evil
inside of you and I'm like she read in
the comments everyone should go Tim
[ __ ] love you guys I'm like this is
her perspective of that like she just
sees it so much different she just still
sees me as that little boy right my
guess is just comedy that's this funny
stuff right they don't know yeah they
don't know sometimes like yeah like
things that were joking around about you
know like don't think it's super serious
I like toothache comedies fun because
you can push the buttons and make jokes
about stuff that you can't necessarily
you shouldn't almost yeah well that's
the funnest part food I'm lobbies not
comedian but when Tim and I and jxr hey
hanging out we say some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that's like well [ __ ] in the fat chicks
I'm not in fact you gotta have a thing
especially with the look but the end of
times coming dude I'm laying there next
to a bonebag
did you laying next to some girl that
doesn't have any skills yeah last the
end of times coming wrote and you have
to freaking hunt for to know [ __ ] eyes
look at 1 into 4 yeah we're trying to
[ __ ] see if there's any way we could
score some chicks and down here in LA
hey I'm sure you know I've definitely
I've disappointed a lot of women in this
town I'm down at this point someone the
night yeah if you forgot to pay a
hundred but that's what say like if it
comes down to it's like okay this chick
to run for an hour not too far come core
I would hang out yeah oh yeah you could
find somebody effing Utley to hang out
for sure especially during these times
yeah I know that's extra to have the
mask off though that's the only yeah I
might keep going on just in case yeah
it's 50 it's I know that I'm not joking
for a lot of women it's $50 more for no
mask Wow
so that's where we're at here yeah when
you look at like I was listening to one
of your interviews with uh with Ariel
Ariel Helwani and uh you talked about
instead of you said performing and in
instead of fighting just in a way in a
sentence you were using
do you think of it as performing do you
think of it as like I do
I think of it as pure entertainment I've
never thought of fighting I've never
been able to like articulate it how to
say I never thought of fighting as
fighting I've always thought of it as a
sport plus entertainment and I'm just
gonna get really good at this skill
which happens to be fighting punching
kicking choking all the skills and then
go and perform you know and I always in
my head have a better skillset in this
guy so it's like a performance for me
but it's still fighting it's hard it's
hard to explain it but yeah oh yeah
performing oh I could imagine it's hard
yeah but yeah because I'm watching some
of your fights and I'm like yeah it
seems like like some guys you're
watching them fight and it's it's a
fight
yours has this different element where
it's like like I always watch you
sometimes it seems like whenever you get
in the clinch like it's almost like it
bothers you a little because and there's
just my perspective you know because
it's like oh this almost feels looks
tacky like I want to do the like it
doesn't you can't be as artistic when
you're in some of those environments
does it feel like that or is that um it
that comes down to strategy for me I'm
usually like longer almost every single
time I fight someone especially in my
weight class I'm gonna be longer I'm
gonna have the reach advantage so
getting in close and being in the clinch
is gonna be not necessarily a
disadvantage for me but it's not
necessarily where I want to be I want to
be at range right where I can hit people
and they can't hit me if I'm keeping
somebody which is like a front kick to
their sternum if I'm landing that they
can't hit me you know if you watch my
fights I throw a lot of [ __ ] teeth
kiss Oh your legs like seem like they
got arms and yeah they don't might is my
hands are just many kicks so once we're
in the clinch it gives them an
opportunity to grab my hips get a body
lock take me down but we've been working
on so much jujitsu and I and I'm getting
called out by these wrestlers and and I
don't usually I don't read comments and
get offended they're like oh you need a
[ __ ] fight a wrestler to prove you're
real but I do a lot of jiu-jitsu a lot
of ground training I do way more
grappling than I do anything so I'm
gonna [ __ ] choke these [ __ ]
like once I get someone that can
actually take me down like I guarantee
the hose etiquette I thought before
Eddie his goal his jiu-jitsu tattooed
across his chest his goal was to take
the time he means he was trying to take
me down but you right exactly forever
you better really mean it but the thing
is is like these guys think oh they're
just good we got to take him down grab
good luck grab and hold me my distance
and my footwork and my speed is you know
that's something we work on and
understanding where I'm at on the cage
it's not easy to take me now it's not
easy to grab me without getting [ __ ]
punched in the jaw or need or hit in the
stomach so so these people that I think
that the way to beat me hey let's just
take him down right that's not a good
game plan right and it's cuz it's not
easy you're like a dangerous water man
when I'm watching you out there I'm like
damn this guy it's almost like somebody
like you have a puppeteer almost and the
person who's doing it is like definitely
been on some speed balls I could've been
up for a couple days you know I feel
like when I'm in there and I've said
this in other interviews like I feel
like I just let go of all thought and
everything and I feel like my higher
self takes control of me in there so I
do I am like a [ __ ] puppet to my
Higher Self and just doing everything
that I'm just doing whatever that
puppets making me do that's right well
you feel coachable like do you feel is
it do you find it's harder to be like
take like pointers from coaches and
stuff as you grow cuz I mean you're like
oh no you're literally on like a rocket
ship right now like this is a unique
time in your life
does it get because your own voice gets
big you know because people tell you
it's big I see your work and it's a-you
know you're you're undefeated you're
like okay I know what I'm doing and does
that make it tough to to hear coaches as
much not at all because like tankini o
gusto Mendez is our jiu-jitsu coach who
that's who Tim got his black belt under
and he's just won a TCC world's last
year which is the biggest grappling
tournament and he's the best in that
weight class which is my weight class at
grappling I'm never gonna out learn him
there's none there's never gonna be a
time where I'm like I don't he can
always teach me forever and then for MMA
it's like Tim and I Tim knows my style
my striking my jujitsu better than
anyone he knows that like as well as I
know it so I try
when he says something like you can see
there's new I've watched all my fights
off [ __ ] thousands times there's
moments in the fight where you can hear
Kim yell something from the cage and you
can see you'll see me do it the same
what he's yelling in because we have
code words for everything so in the
fight I'm super coach bomb soup I'm
trusting in him like he sees something
and I know I trust that that's gonna
work in there and it has so far but as
far as being outside the fighting like
okay it's time to Train I mean you could
answer that if I'm coachable I feel like
I take take it well yeah but super
[ __ ] smart you know and I don't look
at and say hey you need to do this say
hey look at it from this perspective
what do you think he's like oh [ __ ] that
makes sense now I see that a little bit
so it's super [ __ ] coachable for sure
yeah what was it like whenever you guys
went over to Joe Rogan I know you're a
huge Joe Rogan fan you me too and I
remember the first time walking into
like his lair it's like I feel like for
me I felt like I walked into like like
where they wrote the Bible and my but
the Bible had like some crazy different
chapters like people were you know
people were [ __ ] arm wrestling and
before you know eating [ __ ] albatross
nuggets and just doing wild [ __ ] you
know yeah that's what was y'all's
experience like when you guys went over
there I was nervous as [ __ ] me too I'm
like who in the night before I got this
Airbnb and I didn't look at it I'm like
two miles from Rogen's place I figure
it'll be a nice little place it's some
ghetto ass apartment audio studio one
bedroom one bed man it's like so Tim and
I are [ __ ] sleeping in that bed and
I'm like under the top covers he's
it's a uncomfortable just greasy just
greasy in the box
haha pictures of the apartment or of
like the lady and her family that lived
in there and it was just [ __ ] awkward
it wasn't awkward it was and it was like
weird to be in there cuz it didn't feel
clean yeah and then we so we got
caffeined up and went into Rogen's and
uh I was [ __ ] nervous I'm like I know
his podcasts are long three hours he's
[ __ ] super smart I feel like half
[ __ ] half the time yeah especially
around you know my god but I felt like
it got it went good yet our - I feel
complete
li I feel like one of those people they
got molested in the wheelchair honestly
brah no offense but like I feel at our -
I don't know how he keeps going man yeah
it's impressive and he never has to get
up and pee I I think I remember if I got
up and peed but I remember having to pee
but you always just [ __ ] toughs it
out yeah I get afraid to pee him in
there like I was like yeah I was yeah I
was nervous like what do I do this drink
it like what do i do like yeah we're
supposed to be yeah what would you okay
- yeah Rogen's the [ __ ] man it's
crazy how how influential he is nowadays
- yeah sweet though like all the guests
you have on there you can have funny ass
[ __ ] on there really really
smart
[ __ ] on there or high level
athletes and he can relate with all of
them and talk and have a good
conversation smart smart [ __ ]
it's sweet that we are able to listen to
him like that oh yeah man yeah he's so
curious it's like um at a time it's
funny at a time where where people kind
of hurry to make choices and decisions
and hurry through everything it feels
like he goes long form and he's so
curious like he genuinely like wants to
know yeah and I think it helps the rest
of us that you know learned yeah for
sure I've learned a ton listening to his
podcast for though over the years yeah
even like like I know I don't know what
the [ __ ] I don't know about politics I
don't know what a Republican I don't
know I don't know far I don't only
politics I ever [ __ ] they ever heard
of his from you know Rogen's yeah pretty
interesting listening to their
perspectives on that yeah when he had
Bernie Sanders on I thought it was real
interesting cuz I didn't know exactly
like I mean you hear all these like
little clips online and stuff but to get
like a real idea of sitting down and
listening to somebody you get to know
them a little better you know for sure I
thought I was a lot more real yeah for
sure I think that's how most those talk
should go like the important ones yeah
long conversations like that instead of
like they say 30 seconds commercial I'm
crazy do WOM when you see this picture
yourself like we had a picture you when
you were up on Rogan that was like two
years ago
yeah is that interesting to look back at
that guy's it just seemed like the same
dude yeah I feel like for me you should
always look
a couple years a long time to be able to
grow mentally I feel like I learned
because that was right after my fight
where I broke my foot right so I was I
was learning a lot at that time I was
kind of I was on that I was on that
[ __ ] rocket ship that I'm on now I
was blowing up my one eye I want my
debut I just won won my second fighting
UFC I broke my foot got a lot of
attention because I fought with broken
foot for three minutes ended up winning
and I don't think and your suspension
came after that yeah right right after
July [ __ ] I don't remember all that time
feels like is so um yeah I think I got
suspended after that which was another
two years at out and it was just [ __ ]
crazy that whole that whole from the
time I broke my foot until that last
fight against Jose was it was over a
little over two years and it was just so
much I went through two surgeries was
was on the rogue and went through two
suspensions yeah yeah that was a long
two years but I feel like I learned so
much about about myself and I'm just
like way more grateful for what I had
going through all that stuff yeah I
could imagine that sitting out and
watching everything go on and just
thinking okay where would I be in this
would I be in this fight right here like
yeah was there a fighter during that
time you're like oh that guy's taking my
place well I was supposed to fight a
supposed to fight El techo the kid I
knocked out on March 7th I supposed to
fight him got suspended and then my
suspension was up and then I'm supposed
to fight Chito and I got suspended again
so I was like [ __ ] watching these guys
fight and I'm supposed to be fighting
you guys but I did like I said I got
those two surgeries which made me way
more of an athlete like I felt like I
needed those I had a torn labrum in my
hip button both my UFC fights both my
first and second UFC fight I had the
torn labrum so is it was affecting my
performance a lot so I was able to get
healthy and I was able to do a lot of
jiu-jitsu like really commit my entire
life to jiu-jitsu and getting good where
I was lacking like that's where someone
was gonna beat me
years ago as if they took me down and
they could lay on me now I don't feel
like someone could do that yeah so I'm
looking back at it it was the best thing
that happened I was able to really
commit to jiu-jitsu and get a strength
and conditioning program the fight
against Andre I was walking around 149
probably like heaviest one friend the
fighting is El techo I was walk around
157 158 so I was able to put on a lot of
muscle that was like [ __ ] not just
muscle to where I'm like God I'm jacked
but muscle in all the right places my
legs my everything was we're we're
training lifting for MMA Brandon Harris
my strength and conditioning coaches the
[ __ ] man weight like we were lifting
for MMA so it's perfect do you feel is
there a weight that you really feel the
best that you feel like you're still
learning it because I mean even at your
age you're still kind of your body still
kind of adjusted I mean I'm 40 I'm older
so it's like you know I know that my
body kind of goes through some things
where you know sometimes it feels like
oh it's pretty hype and sometimes it
feels like okay I'm still kind of
figuring it out yeah I hired this guy
named Dan Garner's on nutritionist we I
got my [ __ ] tested my piss tested my
saliva tested jeeps got everything
tested and figured out what causes would
you figure out your [ __ ] high as [ __ ]
[ __ ] in this little container and ship
Italy Mike it was weird
yeah but I got all that stuff tested so
I can figure out what causes
inflammation in my body and what what
foods do really well so I got my diet
dialed the [ __ ] in like perfect I'm
eating perfect in camp and I'm feeling
like a [ __ ] machine on it's crazy
when you eat perfect those little
injuries that you have in your wrist or
your knee or your back tight those
little injuries go away they're not
there anymore there's no more
inflammation in my body cuz I'm eating
the right food so with the my food on
point like my diets [ __ ] perfect my
what my weight cut was good the strength
and conditioning and then my MMA
training I'm like I'm everything's at
such a high level as far as my coaches
mm-hmm that I'm just destined to be
[ __ ] great with everyone around me
right being a package yeah do you feel
um do you feel like I know you just got
off of a fight do you and I heard you
talking about like you know you don't
have a manager right right and I don't
have a manager right like it's one way
that I've
my own business and there's things that
I like about it there's moments where I
get scared where it's kind of like okay
what do I do in this instance a little
bit like this is where I would have an
extra layer of protection to talk to
someone I'll have to make those calls
and stuff what's that experience kind of
been like for you not having one yeah
for me I was like I think a lot of
fighters are fooled I'm like you guys
can't do this you guys are some fighters
give 20% of their purse they make
$100,000 they're given 20,000 asker
their manager yeah you know mine was
only 10% right but still I'm like I'm
gonna give 10% of my manager because he
signed a couple emails
it was weird negotiated my contractor do
UFC when I was the one that was sitting
there talking to the UFC and he was
sitting next we didn't say [ __ ] didn't
say a word and I'm sitting there talking
so I had to pay him you know a lot of
money to get out of the contract but it
was worth it and as far as dealing with
those things you know my dad's helped me
out a lot nice I have a lawyer to look
over contract perfect yeah um and then I
have I have other people that I can hit
up if I need to that are in the industry
- them yeah so yeah that's a big thing
is how do I get through this moment like
what would you do here exactly so that's
that's nice
and just not burning bridges anywhere
just always having good relationships
with so many people to be able to ask it
is nice but you know I'm getting
messages from other fighters but hey you
have a manager what's going on Mike dude
if you can sit down like i sat down with
UFC Sean Shelby and we talked he's like
I there's some fighters I can't talk to
I'd have to have that middle person
because if I tell them hey you're not
worth this this why and they get go I am
it did I'm like okay I want me and you
just sit down be fair talk to me like
I'm my my own manager don't talk to me
like I'm the fighter right let's be
[ __ ] fair I don't see why that's so
hard but I know they're trying to pay me
the least amount of money throw out
there and fight and I'm trying to make
myself the most amount of money let's
meet in the middle and be [ __ ] fair
and I think we're getting there i sat
down with UFC after my last fight we
didn't have a written out contract in
numbers but we agreed like okay this
this should be fair so it's getting done
and it feels good to be like knowing I'm
in charge of this [ __ ]
feels good who were guys that you can
reach out to you feel like like are
there guys out there if you need
suggestions as for negotiate in the
contract yeah or just yeah that kind of
stuff like do you have kind of mentors
within the business you feel like I feel
like um for for managing sponsorship
contracts I have a couple people that
I'm working with right now without
signing a contract with them just so I
can ask them they can help me get
conduct but when it comes to just fine I
feel like I haven't had to reach out to
anybody but if I did I feel like I could
reach out to a couple people and even if
they're like Nam I can't help you like
even Chael Sonnen like this [ __ ]
knows a lot of [ __ ] I have his number
i've text him a couple times if i was
like i don't know what to do maybe I
asked jail yeah the [ __ ] knows a
lot I haven't reached out to him
personally for anything really yet and
if I have to some day maybe I will but
even Anthony Smith's and ufc's yeah he's
a great guy he met her I was on the
phone with him doing a pod care power
need anything or what happening
questions reach out let me know guys
like that and then obviously I have a
bunch of friends at the UFC but I feel
like I'm doing good right now and I'm
taking care of what needs to be taken
care of and if I'm happy with my
contract right that's a big thing yeah
you know if you're happier yeah yeah so
I think and so far it's going good yeah
yeah it's nice what uh what are you been
doing in your downtown like say you get
off of a fight like you know you got
maybe do you guys take a week off what
does that look like dude
you guys go to the water slaughter so
you guys do water slots I can take a
week off that'd be crazy my I [ __ ]
enjoy training so much it's part of it's
just part of life I quite [ __ ] love
it mom a water slide sounds pretty fun
no but I don't know it's training just
part of life and I enjoy I enjoy it so
much we train you know when I'm in camp
I don't smoke so I enjoyed smoking
outside of camp whether I'm like last
Sunday was pro I got high [ __ ] yeah
golden have your old key in jujitsu uh
like in the butter you mean ya know in
Aggie like the looking pajamas okay
I know you're talking about yeah I got
highest [ __ ] I took a puff off the
sativa joint Sunday and we did flow I
flowed for the most part my shins
[ __ ] bruised his [ __ ] and it hurts
even touch but I did jujitsu that's part
of the most fun practice I've ever had
in my life just flowing in Agee going
from positions to positions and I just
really enjoy training jiu-jitsu I enjoy
hitting mitts and stuff but we we
usually hit mitts and really up the
striking aim camp and we have a fight
booked and sparring I don't really I
don't spar outside outside a camp just
pretty much do Jiu Jitsu and strength
and conditioning but what's your like
finishing move do you have like a
finishing I got a [ __ ] up I have more
finishing techniques than anybody ever
because I can stand both stances and do
everything from both stances and I have
I have just as much power my left hand
is my right hand and my like
everything's just the sugar show who
would I sway it is it's [ __ ] sweet
and I thought I've had a lot of sweet
finishes I don't know if you've seen the
one where a head kick that do it yeah
that one that one's one of my all time
for that's what I was really looking for
I thought I was gonna catch Eddie with
that because his hands were so low I
thought I didn't catch him with
something spinning but he gotta fight
suck he's from was like the 1800 or
something you know he comes in like he's
got a shankster yeah yeah he was the
nicest [ __ ] - I legitimate Lee
felt bad knocking him out as he was
fluttering down yeah yeah does that
happen sometimes is there times where
you get in there and because sometimes
like I'll even notice like just talking
to friends of mine who were in the sport
even just talking to friends money were
in the sport a while yeah I dropped him
with my left hand
[ __ ] yeah and now that was a couple
years ago but another walk off you think
you could have got you how you think if
they would have given him you know
left-handed think you see how guys ever
pretend to be out I bet they do this
dink oh yeah no I killed him basically
no yeah they that I on kuta lava fight
verse Megaman he was kind of acting like
he was yeah and then they they stopped
the fight I believe that I believe that
it's probably scary getting rocked and
you're like I just get me out of here
yeah and you can't climb out of the top
right that'd be sweet if someone did
that me
[ __ ] sweet but you can't do don't put
a top on it no they they probably you
know dqu or whatever but you ever
getting [ __ ] up dipping take cabbage I
am dipping now can you legally climb on
to the top and jump off a ladder you can
see I don't know if you can't grab
inside the fence but you could kind of
run up the cage probably but I see
that's another finish we got somewhere
locked in like is a cage kick like I
don't know Anthony Pettis hit that on
Benson but he didn't finish him there's
not really been any sweet finishes
jumping off the cage right and and we
definitely could could land something
like that soon yeah because I want to
know how sweet the sugar show can get
yeah I wanna see much disappear no I
can't do that we're just getting started
like I'm 25 and and I gotta easily
another 10 years yeah you know but the
way I eat and the way I train and the
way I take care of my body I'm still
gonna be I think 36 37 38 I'm still
gonna be [ __ ] good yeah so I plan on
being in this sport for a long time and
getting a lot of [ __ ] sweet finishes
so when you're out there we know
whenever you whenever you get in into
the end of the Octagon do you think
about like are you already kind of
thinking about the finish as the fight
goes on if it starts to feel comfortable
to you start to think like oh I can
finish this right now but I'm gonna wait
a minute does that ever kind of happen
or it's not like there's too much
intensity in that last fight when I hit
him with that body kick the spinning
body kick I've dropped a lot of people
with that and that [ __ ] was so
tough he tried toughing it out if you
get have you been hitting a liver hard
he just paralyzed and bro I still
[ __ ] every time I eat a snicker my
[ __ ] body hurts eluded but he still
tried like after I landed that I'm
taking this dude out I knew I was gonna
take him out um because of that just
hitting someone that that shot is so
dangerous and so powerful and I've
landed it so many times and at that
point you start to feel like a hunter at
that point yeah I felt like okay I'm
getting this dude out of here but I
wanted that spin kick I missed it barely
because I hit him with the left body
kick deep
and I threw a right right hook and it
landed hard and then I switched stances
and threw a spinning kick that's what I
wanted for the finish but that's in that
moment I knew I was about to get him out
of there that's why I spun know what I
tried to take his [ __ ] head off you
spun myself around but I knew I had him
hurt and I did think okay how am I gonna
finish this dude and that's why I wanted
that spin kick bad but then it missed
and I was like I don't want to gas
myself out just dinked him yeah do you
um do you feel like like what do you
think there's something unique about
your body type or just like you did
you're some gift that makes it how
you're able to kind of flow the way that
you do like where do you think it comes
from do you think that it just comes
from training do you think like what do
you really feel like yeah I feel like I
was definitely gifted athletically just
being an athlete and being able to move
the way I do um I played basketball
football soccer baseball growing up till
I was about 16 that's when I started
kickboxing but I think playing all those
sports made me like a pretty good
athlete and then once I started
kickboxing I would never really taught
hands up left in it like how to throw
properly yeah because we just go in spar
and I would yeah I think I would just
flow switch stances throw [ __ ] and it
would that just became my style just
switching stances and doing stuff like
that and then slowly kind of building on
that but you know a lot of coaches were
like not listen you can't do that you're
gonna you're gonna get beat up you're
getting knocked out put your hands up
I've been told that literally since I
started fighting right like some people
get mad at me put your [ __ ] hands up
while I'm sparring but you like to do it
your way but I'm like my hand getting
hit right hands out that these 16-ounce
gloves are too [ __ ] heavy for my
little ass arms to pull up I'm gonna
keep him down low and that's just kind
of how I've developed my style and it's
worked out and then I think the work I
put in is not just [ __ ] hard work but
I work smart yeah I have a hot tube at
home a cold plunge at home a sauna at
home a mat room where I can stretch a
foam roll I have all these tools to
where I can recover and in eat perfect
and then I go train hard the next day
and if I don't if I don't feel like I
can train hard I'll take that day off
and and I think Michael Bisping coach
said it takes confidence
to take a day off because when you have
a fight coming up that you're thinking
[ __ ] I gotta get in shape for that fight
I can't take today off right and I swear
a lot of people get hurt but I feel like
there's no way to properly rest I'm so
in tune with my body and know what it
needs to do I know if I need a rest I
know if I can push so I think that that
helps me I get that confidence to get in
the cage and get into that flow state
where I'm just purely confident do you
feel like in y'all's aah I know we're
talking about kind of like moving weight
and stuff is there anybody that's kind
of like retired or anything to you
whenever you over the past few years
like oh [ __ ] I always hoping maybe
somewhere in the back of my head one day
to get to fight that guy I think I think
Henry will uh I think that'll be a fight
someday could be a big fight so who did
the Cabaye arrow on hey I think that
could be a big fight some day and he got
really offended I don't know if you seen
my comment after my fight they asked me
about him retiring about his girlfriend
you mean I said he's 30 you got his
first girlfriend he got it really that
stung him really he posted on his
Instagram he went on Joe bro let's talk
about Sean O'Malley
I got a so on that poked at him so if
someone's that insecure and easy to poke
at he's gonna want to fight me right but
if he's smart he probably won't because
he said well he needs to work on his
wrestling and juju I guess is getting
pretty good that's what I said on Rogan
but like I'm telling you people think oh
let's just take him down I'm gonna choke
them or I'm gonna I'm gonna do I'm gonna
submit him or I'm gonna get back up it's
not gonna be it's not gonna be like they
grab me take me down and fights over
Romney to get back up I'm gonna choke
him off my back elbow him it's not gonna
it's um I can I can scrap I can get
scrappy down there so that could be a
big fight someday I don't think he's
done I think he's you know if you're in
your prime for I don't know it's for me
if I'm in my prime it's hard to put
yourself in that position because Nick
don't you retire as the king or do you
cuz I heard you talk about this like
you'd like to just keep going eat almost
rather lose Nick I try I gave him my
everything instead of no I'm too
insecure my egos too big to lose what do
you think is a weakness in his game I
mean I mean his that's him he's the
highest level you get that's a high
level black belt MMA fighter he can box
he can wrestle I don't know about his
but when you're wrestling that
high-level he does almost need that much
jujitsu if he gets the takedown he can
control on the top posture up
ground-and-pound
he's [ __ ] really really good you
definitely the best bantamweight and
then he retired obvious was Cruz's last
fighter he had one yeah after that no
Christmas do you think that would be a
fight for United me what do you think
that I think I'd knock Cruz out - I
think his style just it I feel like I'd
knock them all out so it's hard to say
but but if you had your choice like say
it's you know you get up in the morning
you have a full day of knocking people
out okay
who do you knock out for breakfast who
do you knock out for lunch and who do
you knock out for that tasty
okay late meal right throw a 4th one in
there - because I get snack you want to
get high knock out Cody for breakfast
okay my blood moving okay I'd probably
knock out TJ after that just brunch yeah
then I'd knock out Dominic and then I'd
me Henry in the face while he's shooting
so I probably do those four and then
call it and then probably call out Conor
Wow yeah just fried midnight just for
fun and I hope you know [ __ ] that would
be [ __ ] that he's crazy huh oh I'm none
of that now when you see a guy like a
beat fight I mean he's aw you know one
thing that you know whenever he was
fighting whenever him and dust and
fought no I almost wished that and this
is look I admit I'm a newcomer to the
sport but almost wished that for a
certain amount of the fight they had to
be on their feet and then a certain
amount of the fight that they didn't
have to be they couldn't be right that
one resting no yeah because that that
changes the whole game Dustin could
definitely got some of the best boxing
in the USC he's got really good [ __ ]
hands he's got a sweet fight coming up
first and hooker yeah that's gonna be a
great man but yeah and then when you
fight hubby bits it's just such a it's
like wearing like you know that blanket
they sell you on the internet all the
time it weighs like 80 pounds or
something yeah and it will wave you
alone yeah it's like somebody bought you
seven of those for Christmas dude yeah
that would be a yeah that would be a
tough fight to even prepare for and just
yeah it's almost like you do have to
hide yourself under a bunch of rocks and
then just [ __ ] yeah just yeah that's
good that'd be a good way to train for
land or a bunch of rock getting up
[ __ ] dude yeah that's a tough fight I
was he almost had that guillotine that
guillotine was tight Habibi even said
that was [ __ ] tight yeah could you
imagine if you were to finish that that
would have been legendary that I've been
insane but I do think Justin gay Chi
does have a has a pretty good chance
yeah compared to the you know the rest
of guys Habib's fought as far as their
wrestling accolades like Justin could
definitely give him a [ __ ] fight yeah
have you watched much of him I haven't
watched a ton of him I've watched maybe
three the recent ones yeah I guess let
me think um the one with Tony you
probably watch yep I definitely watch
that one that was unbelievable dude
that's all only fight you gotta watch
then [ __ ] love Justin gate see and I
looked you know what I actually looked
and made me really love both of him
really yeah because it made me respect
Tony at like a just watching these guys
like you're talking to a guy like my big
thing when I was young was kind of
getting my ass beat yeah that's so cool
dude it is pretty cool like so dude like
I almost even when you when when you
were coming today I was like man I
almost want him to [ __ ] knock me out
yeah I saw I could like be a part of
that would be fun we could spar because
I sparred this kid from Canada I flew
him down he was one of my twitch
subscribers and we sparred we did three
threes Tim was the ref and it something
really cool I might you two it's [ __ ]
hilarious because he would never he
always talk [ __ ] to me about like in a
friendly way but right and it was just
fun as [ __ ] but he started jiu-jitsu
after that and he stayed consistent
which is cool awesome but it was a
perfect like I obviously know Mike no
Mike control and hey yeah we did at the
lab I saw I didn't beat him up bad to
where he left like hurt right like he
was puking tired and just like wow it
was it was one of the it was my favorite
fight I've ever been and it was so
[ __ ] funny I think deal might catch
you like with you sleeve yeah do might
come in the right hand yeah I would
probably use my legs more we sure that
would be [ __ ] good ass video and it
would be fun it's good for I would like
to learn that because it yeah feels
almost to see what that's like like um
one thing that out that was awesome the
first time that Dustin came on he was
talking about like whenever you go
through a fight like whenever you get
through a fight like win or lose like
you learn there's like you learn
something about yourself at like a at a
level that we can't really duplicate
less it's that and
2/3 I agree 100% that in weight cuts I
think everyone should go through a
weight cut in a fist fight like
kickboxing fight yeah the weight cuts
are so it's crazy what goes through your
mind when your does last a couple days
because kind of Native American doesn't
it what do you mean I got feel like the
weight cuts like I feel like when you
get to those last couple pounds I mean
dude I almost I didn't eat for six days
once and almost [ __ ] eat a dude at
Best Buy yeah almost [ __ ] business
fasting oh yeah I almost bit into a
[ __ ] guy you know beautiful yeah I
mean I looked [ __ ] yeah like you
start to think of it dude like if the
power went out this dude yeah dad
especially you know some jujitsu I think
it that real kill you into you that's
what's so powerful about jujitsu really
know you're in the if you know you're in
a [ __ ] place and you got to eat right
you kill them eat them right yeah you
have that inner skill yes otherwise I
gotta like come here with a [ __ ] bat
or something yeah I got a sneak up I
gotta poison them as long as just learn
a rear-naked choke a good clean one you
can sneak up on anybody and eat them
yeah but but those last few days through
a weight cut like Thursday morning and I
wake up like all right today's gonna
suck yeah
damn you're no water and hardly any food
but then you also what goes through my
mind also is like there's like the
people who suffer way worse and other
countries like that don't have food or
water like I can go shower
a clean water and people don't have that
so I it's always a good perspective to
remind yourself like oh yeah life still
[ __ ] good you can you could look at
pictures of food on your phone yeah
you'll be great just being grateful for
the things that you yeah that we still
have but that's what's so good about
those weight cuts it can really show you
like teach you a lot and it's approach
and it's also like it's really never
thought about this but it's kind of like
a it's like I'm almost a red carpet up
to the fight it almost it's like a
respect because they're doing it as well
yeah so it's like both you guys are kind
of like yeah we're gonna condition
ourselves for this war we're about to go
in [ __ ] yeah and the thing about weight
cutting too is like if this guy doesn't
know if he's not eating perfect like I
am and he's not doing exactly what he
needs to do like I got that [ __ ] down to
a sigh
I'm doing everything perfect and this
guy's not that's an advantage for me
going into the fight yeah and I feel
like if I feel like whoever I'm
Fighting's not gonna be doing the exact
thing that I'm doing and I feel like I'm
always gonna have a little advantage
there so it's good mentally going to the
fight too especially some guys like will
weigh in before that fight when I felt
Jose
we weighed in Quinn Quinn garrison
genius yeah Jose Quinonez we walked
walked past the buffet or whatever and
these fighters just weighed in like an
hour ago and they're eating french toast
and syrup and just a bunch of [ __ ] I'm
gonna just
[ __ ] you all we [ __ ] Brendan he
probably did that [ __ ] oh really
definitely way dude at least one time he
[ __ ] showed me a rare stick of butter
he got someone in the pocket of another
country don't tell nobody
well yeah Fighting's a [ __ ] crazy
sport and then the weight cut on top of
it's almost a sport itself yeah it seems
like better support for this past
weekend comes from manscaped who is
number one in men's below the belt
grooming manscaped offers precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
you nuts you got to take care of your
body and some of your body includes your
nuts and pecker and all of that lower
body and you know these days you just
got a you don't want to snag something
down there you don't want to be you know
you know you don't want to get a fish
hook or something snagged over down by
your nuts so you got to tighten your
body up and nobody helps you do that
more than manscaped manscaped is forever
changing the grooming game with their
perfect package 2.0 inside the perfect
package you'll find their electric
trimmer called the lawnmower 2.0 this
waterproof and skin safe technology will
protect you from nicking your bag that's
right
you can you could you could trim your
your body in the shower now it's
waterproof its skin safe
you're not gonna Nick you're nuts you're
gonna be fine you're not gonna bleed
get 20% off in free shipping and support
the podcast with the code Theo
th EO at manscaped comm that's right get
20% off in free shipping and support the
podcast with code Theo
at manscaped dot-com that's 20% off in
free shipping at manscape com used code
Theo to carry your body it also comes
with the crop preserver and anti chafing
ball deodorant and moisturizer so take
care of your body man it's your body and
it's your penis in it you nuts
be good huh today's episode is brought
to you by blue chew fellows do you
remember when you were fully ready in
your body for sex when you would think
about sex and just be able to be erect
remember when your body just knew what
to do well it can happen again you can
increase your performance and get that
extra confidence in bed blue to calm
that's blue like the color blue blue Chu
brings you the first chewable with the
same fda-approved active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis you can take them any
time day or night even on a full stomach
you've already had spaghetti you've
already had a couple pieces of banana
nut bread it doesn't matter
have a chewable wiener upper that's
right they work twice as fast as a pill
so you can be ready whenever the
opportunity arises benefit from the
confidence blue chew the fast and easy
way to enhance your performance it is
prescribed online by licensed physicians
so you don't have to go to the doctor or
wait in line at the pharmacy it ships
right to your door they're made in the
USA and it ships direct so they are
cheap right now we got a special deal
for our listeners you can support the
podcast visit blue chew comm and get
your
first shipment free when you use our
special promo code Theo just pay $5
shipping again that's BL you e CH e
w.com promo code th e o to try it free
blue chew is the better cheaper faster
choice and we thank them for sponsoring
the podcast we had a question that came
in here we got a young fella right here
that sent in a question for us let's get
into it right here this beautiful white
right here o bunch of beautiful whites
yeah
sup boys Brady from Asheville North
Carolina originally from Montana four of
six Sean my question for you is with Tim
being your best friend and your head
coach do you ever find it difficult
knowing when to turn off one of those
relationships and have him be just your
coach or just your best friend so I got
Gang Gang buzzbuzz gang bruh Gang Gang
yeah that's a good question I get i
actually get asked that quite a bit on I
feel like even when it's coaching we're
still [ __ ] around
right but we know when it's when it's a
serious and hey this I don't know I feel
like we've never had an issue with that
to where it's like hey I'm coaching
right now we always know like the goals
world champ I want to be the best ever
so both you guys have the same goal and
we have that goal in mind so we know
when when when to [ __ ] around and when
to turn it off and train and we've never
had an issue with that Tim now let's
hear your side of it yeah same [ __ ] as
soon as we get in the gym and it's time
to work it that were there to [ __ ]
work we still [ __ ] around but like said
that's the main goals be world champ
so once though once it's time to get
that session done we get it done yeah
recently like obviously you know like I
was watching some of your interviews and
stuff and there's times in it where I'm
like oh Sean's very confident and then
I'm like Sean is very Flambeau you know
he's like he's a show you know they call
it the sugar show you know and I start
to get like okay I kind of see what's
going on here sometimes you say
something I'm like Jesus I can't believe
your buckets said that like I go through
all these range of emotions when I'm
watching your interviews right do you
know like um like do you start to and
and I noticed this myself as I started
to get more popularity like your ego is
a thing that lives inside and it's kind
of scary sometimes because it's like
okay what's confidence
what's ego when when do I kind of turn
on one on in turn you know do you notice
some of that inside of yourself yeah
when I wear my sugar chain mm-hmm sugars
out that's my ego I know I know I know
when I need to do well I got the gym I
want people to treat me as Shawn I got
this and I feel like I do a really good
job about turning that off and being and
not being in my head like I'm I'm sugar
I'm the man the [ __ ] I knock people
out when I do interviews I kind of just
I just I feel like when the confidence
the confidence is real it's true I think
people can tell when someone's really
confident when they're trying to fake it
um
that's probably my ego too but almost in
a healthy way
you know Unni I feel like you need that
if you want to get to the level that you
want to get to because it seems like you
not only want to be a champion you want
to be a I want to be one of the best to
ever fight like I think and I think with
my athletic ability and my skill set
that's constantly improving I'm gonna be
I can definitely get there I think yeah
and it's always a battle ego in your
true self and in being like when I'm at
home with Danny my girl our relationship
is so good and it's like it's me it's
Shawn and Danny and if it's sugar and
Danny it collides almost in a way it's
hard to it's hard to talk about the ego
too you know it's hard to talk about
look it's interesting yeah it is
interesting but and then we listen to
guys like Eckhart Tolle and in [ __ ]
holiday right yeah Ryan holiday the the
stoic books and who's the awareness guy
oh I think de Melo Anthony de Mello and
just listening to [ __ ] these smart
guys talked about and talked about
happiness and what's true happiness and
and stuff like that it's a trip to think
about my ego and then my my real self my
true self almost an understanding that I
have an ego and I can't beast I can't
get stuck in that ego right after the
fight I gotta come back to show and when
I'm home right
at home and it's been with my dogs and
Danny I'm I gotta be Shawn I can't
constantly be that ego you get lost in
that [ __ ] world I lost in your ego and
then you're never yourself and then it's
like harder to bring back hard to come
back to your true self so I feel like I
do good about mixing it up and no one
when to be sugar and knowing when to be
Shawn Sugar's next so sugars obviously
you know like um there's a couple of
ways you could kind of do the next
couple years of your life you know and
you know you could go kind of I bet if
they wanted to they would offer you yeah
you want to fight you know you know once
you guys might be pissed yeah but if you
want to fight straight up you know if
you want to go you know and get closer
to the top and have us chance at the at
the strap now or it's like you want to
take your way up like what do you what
do you feel like it's truly gonna be
best for you there's you know UFC is a
business a really really smart
intelligent business and I'm a [ __ ]
star in the making like it's clear the
audience is attracted to what I have to
put out and I'm a high-level performer
so they got to build me like a business
owner but me as a fighter I'm like I can
like fight I feel like I'm the best I
can fight anybody and beat them so we
got to just kind of figure out what's
next take smart fights but also like I
found Eddie Wineland he's not an easy
fight and like some people say oh
they're giving you bums
Eddie wine there's not a [ __ ] bomb at
all Eddie wildin will beat all of our
[ __ ] dad's ass exactly Eddie the
wines a bad [ __ ] so they're not
giving me fight Jose Quinonez was like
six and one in the UFC he wasn't an easy
fight right um so I see people on there
saying that give me these fights and
stuff but I think the us he's gonna
build me smart and in my next fight it's
gonna be another tough tougher fight
than Eddie but not super because
realistically fighting anybody in the
top ten is a tough [ __ ] fight for me
I'm not gonna go out there smoking yeah
this is the top ten in the world in the
way house so no fights easy especially
when you know what those [ __ ] little
gloves and people throw bombs yeah so
any fights not a gimme fight but I think
they're gonna try to do it smart build
me up smart that's what they're gonna
try to do what would you try to do I
think
like a businessman - I know I'm only in
the sport for you know ten years can
sound like a long time but once I'm once
it's over I'm like [ __ ] did I do that
right I want to look back and go I did
that right I'm getting called out by a
lot of a lot of wrestlers and I feel I'm
like God I want to fight these
[ __ ] like Cooper like what do
you mean like wrestlers like you mean
like guys that literally want to grab my
legs hold me down and not fight like
merabh that kids I saw last last weekend
all I think man like [ __ ] wrestlers
do from the WWE I don't know real
wrestling Oh guys oh wow okay like
scared to fight right but love to
grapple and wrestle just a thermic crab
kind of dude yeah
and it's a risky fight for me to take
because it doesn't cater to your strong
suits doesn't know what you like to do
yeah I like knock people out but I'd
like I'm when I think of myself as a I
feel like I'm really good at Jiu Jitsu
but it's a risky fight taken against
someone that literally will take it on
I'll hold you there so yeah it's not
what they're lonely calm yeah it's not
what the people want to see it's not you
know but once I'm champ I'll take all
those motherf like it doesn't matter I'm
champ I had to fight who's next
but to get to the champ let's take the
smarter fights and I know a lot of
people ask [ __ ] up your [ __ ] but
definitely you know but it's a business
and everybody it gets to do the business
it's not like they don't like everybody
like like you have some different paths
in it like you have it your own path but
yeah everybody's in the same business
till fighting these guys in the UFC
they're like so and and I think a lot of
the people get jealous like the guys all
your picking fights we're not picking
fights there's I'm not gonna fight
someone that's boring then no one gives
a [ __ ] about no one wants to see me
fight right we're gonna you know what it
means I'm gonna make a smart choice yeah
we got to make a smart choice at the
business what do you think Tim yeah same
thing dude it's like you want to fight a
guy who literally just finally wanted to
dry-hump on you and pump on you and try
to win the rounds by ten nine or do you
want to fight a guy if we fight a
wrestler who comes in there wants to
take him down and beat the [ __ ] out of
them hell you're like a hubby let's do
that ground pound like but some of these
guys literally lay on people oh yeah
and if perverts almost yeah it's they
should get charged you know I mean yes
gay you know
be game over Brown exactly let's meet up
after we have to but don't waste art
that the clock time we got a gentleman
right here who's obviously interested in
it has a question for us
um sugar Sean O'Malley I got a question
what do you think about six nine nine I
want to know I wanna I want to know
about about your head to my [ __ ] love
you I'm a fan I saw you talk about this
before but I want fan-dude
I think it's almost fascinating and I
know the question for you but but I just
stole it but um I think it's just the
dudes fascinating broad like when he
said he's gonna be on @midnight
I [ __ ] showed up I was there I love
that too but then people like all he's
just I don't give a I don't pay
attention to who he snitched on what he
was in jail I don't I don't give a [ __ ]
it I just think his music - we're going
to the gym or before [ __ ] where we're
getting hype I'm throwing on some 6:9
you be' yeah and if I gotta watch the
music video and Nicki Minaj watch that a
couple times I read you see that yes
yeah so I stood let's talk to us but
yeah I'm a fan of his he's a character
yes that is his character is working and
about the hair before we even knew 6:9
like that my debut did we talked about
hey let's do my hair like rain look
crazy and I kind of wanted to establish
my name and UFC get it you know show
that I'm for real and so the hair was
definitely a little bit inspired by like
dude that his hair looks sick it looks
[ __ ] crazy yeah and he's a [ __ ]
character I want to be a character I
want people to be like what the if they
never seen fighting I want them to look
at this screaming oh I want to watch
this guy right you got crazy areas
tallest [ __ ] skinny will you have to
stand out especially if you want to I
mean it's interesting to watch what you
guys do in y'all's business like it's
definitely changed over the past few
years I think with guys calling each
other out more like becoming characters
like everything in the world has kind of
become you know we talked about it a lot
that everything's kind of become like
the WWE a little bit like every like
politicians everybody it's all about
just sound bites and how can i how can I
rise out of whatever's going on and be
seen really absolutely and it definitely
seems like you do that do you think
you'll have a different hairstyle like
do you have other plans for like for
future bounce
yeah
think we're gonna continue with the like
doings different colors my hair Danny my
girl does hair so she did all this so
and she we got a bunch of different
colors so we'll play around with it
maybe I was thinking like uh whoever I
fight next wearing their flag color hair
all if he does just a peck at him like
when I fought Jose I like to say things
that are gonna nudge at him when I
fought Jose I said we'll see who's more
Mexican yeah and he got off yes but then
I get people saying you're racist but my
girls [ __ ] Mexican yeah but just
saying little things that are gonna fire
people up because if I can get someone
emotional to fight me right they're
gonna come forward like Jose today
they're gonna come forward like Eddie
didn't want to take my head off and
that's not a good game playing it
knocked out doing that so if I can get
someone emotional wanna really just hit
me that's good because you you respond
like say if somebody did that to you you
don't respond to it the same how do I
take anything personally right like I
know I understand that you could say I
[ __ ] your mom a big cool like you'd
sell it somebody but my mom yeah my mom
[ __ ] at least probably five people
everybody's mom exactly but it's not
taking anything personally right and
because it's interesting cuz she's so
that's what okay so to you it's like the
game it's a get to show it's a show it's
a [ __ ] it's sugar yeah but I'm I'm
Sean in a way where I'm always kind of
Shonda but I'm not gonna take it
personally right it's gonna be if I take
it personally that's gonna affect how I
fight I might fight emotional right when
I don't fight emotion I fight calm yeah
very calm and I feel like the more calm
I can be the more dangerous I am so if
someone says something and I get
personal about it I think it could
change how I fight it definitely changes
how people fight me know for sure they
get what's how most fights start like if
you're just in regular human interaction
like at a bar post office or whatever
most people fight because somebody gets
[ __ ] pissed
emotional guys like Cody gar Brant who
get mad if you sneeze next to him yeah
it's like holy [ __ ] that's too easy
yeah like I'm sure he's already just
that Holmes wanna fight me do you think
that for him it might be the fight to
take do you feel like meta no I don't
think that's a good fight for him he
needs another fight he needs he's still
on his comeback he's he I'm ranked
number 15 the rankings are pretty much
pretty stupid like as far as who gets
title fights and stuff I'm ranked number
15
just be number two or three or whatever
so he's probably gonna fight me
it's a lose-lose he beats me people I
all you be the number 15 he gets knocked
out obviously it's not a win for him so
I think that's gonna be a big
pay-per-view fight someday right like I
think that's gonna be a big big fight
someday if you're to jump out at like
you know say you're able to get out like
if you were out of the weight class if
you would get into another class who's
somebody you would really love to go at
who the higher up you get the more scary
those [ __ ] get it gets scary
dude I get scared even read a lot of
these charts yeah I can't read them for
I'm trying to go to sleep like the 55
division right there in 77 even 85 or 70
and 85 though those divisions are so
scary those humans are so athletic and
powerful and their skill levels you know
they're high level MMA fighters too so I
definitely wouldn't want to fight any of
them I love when guys like Henry sudo
I'm the baddest [ __ ] on the
world I'm like your 5/3 do we do you
think that bad you're good for your
weight class but dude you're not you
know you're [ __ ] up Francis do you uh
press it will [ __ ] you like smack will
nugget do you think do you think [ __ ] do
you think that um like your confidence
comes from a certain place did you
always have that I think the confidence
that I have carrying into the cage comes
from know when I know I have that foot
that fight booked to the fight day I'm
doing everything right right from like I
talked about my nutrition my sleeps
aren't my sleeps on point you're locked
in my train I'm locked the [ __ ] in so
I'm doing everything right so when I'm
in that backstage I'm not nervous I
don't feel any nerves yeah I'm calm I'm
chilling I'm ready to go out there and
perform because I knew no I did
everything right but there's times where
you know like my last you fight today
really have any injuries which was very
important going into a fight with an
injury could definitely [ __ ] with that
confident right ah like hard I don't
know I haven't really had to go into it
a fight with an injury yet yeah but I
had a torn labrum when I fought those
two guys but I was still able to train
it didn't affect me as much till after
cuz labrum tear they tear tear tear tear
tore to the point where
needed surgery so yeah going to the
fights knowing I'm doing everything
right but even when I was 16 when I
first started for some reason a thousand
go knock these guys out Wow and I was
just a little skinny kid like yeah
that's a different where you I think
good people that don't like to fight
like if I've ever gotten a fight it's
been like [ __ ] I'm not gonna knock this
guy out like Jesus how do i how do I
make this end I don't think you just
flinched and I might not know she that's
a good point brother fighting with that
hard [ __ ] dirty flinch dude that's
true that [ __ ] hide somebody up on
magic imagine if you just rolled out one
day deal with your hair rainbow colored
house just free we're gonna do something
special around the holidays I thought
about doing something seasonal maybe
Thanksgiving a kind of a kind of motif
or we got a question right here from a
young man who took his shirt off yeah
thank you I appreciate you okaythen
accent I see I understand you from money
guys I've got a question here for sugar
if you had a choice what would you be
the best UFC fighter in the world or the
best for tonight player in the world
okay good question yeah I used to play a
lot of [ __ ] fortnight you ever play
that or no huh next play gap seen him
play I don't play it too much anymore I
play more call of duty now or an only
cold you know but definitely I get asked
that like if you could stream and make
more money would you do that Mike
Fighting's my Fighting's what I truly
truly love to do and performing just
being on that fight if I could [ __ ]
this sing or rap or do anything and
perform I [ __ ] want to do it I crave
that yeah so I so definitely fighting
it's fun huh I love performing it's it's
sweet because and when I was like when I
was growing up I didn't literally
remember telling my friends I'm gonna be
famous they're like what how I don't
know I don't know I'm gonna be famous I
don't know why I wanted to be probably
because I was insecure that's probably
what it came from like I want people to
like me
right yeah yeah I always want a studio
so yeah hey watch my fight oh yeah Danny
but uh lower as I said oh yeah
performing
love performing in its I remember
doesn't say something sick though
philosophy for whatever do uh we got a
question right here from a guy open your
eyes fellow Asian a fear my question is
we've seen a lot of buyers struggle in
the day-to-day basis in terms of Finance
you know the cost of living going up by
here food medical petrol training
housing my question to you is should
there be a Fire's Union to help with the
financial side of it you know healthy
low tier fighters we've seen a few weeks
ago brennan royal saying he has to work
a second job a second job and he's in
the UFC should a UFC fighter be having a
second job my question is what the [ __ ]
sides of that bed and how do they really
sleep on it is a is it a toy yeah look
how there's only eight little bars going
across looks like the pen baby yeah that
is a very lean bed this could be a
oldest baby I've ever seen yeah fighters
pay it's weird we look at other sports
making how much money compared to
professionals fighters I mean I don't
obviously know the how much UFC is
making how much Dana making and how much
you know how much we're making and it's
not that much for compared to other
athletes but like guys like Brandon
Royal just won his fight you know that's
at least twenty thousand dollars and he
has to go work a second job it's like
that's his choice
you can quit twenty thousand dollars
will last you a couple months get really
good get another fight booking our fight
perform make another win and and you
don't have to work unless you know maybe
as kids and [ __ ] and I don't know about
but it depends how bad you want it right
at the end of the day I don't even like
talking about the money when I I did
talk about I bring it up because I
wanted the UFC to know I'm I need to
renegotiate that's right I'm gonna bring
it up unless we get to yeah and but I
even if you don't compare it to the
who's the other athletes that are making
so much money and make damn I made 80
G's last fight yeah that's a lot of
[ __ ] money maybe not compared to the
100 mil of that the MLB guys just got
four [ __ ] swinging a baseball bat but
it's still like
we make a lot of money compared to
people that work nine to five s and
write it like that so and it's more
dangerous so I don't know it's tough to
say it's really dangerous I mean I feel
like it's about to change hopefully you
get that feeling Nick that it's about to
change that you guys are about to start
getting paid more you guys I'm not not
one of them but I just know Nick loves
this for yeah but yeah yeah I I just
don't see a union ever happening because
for guys the most influential guys in
the sport like Shawn and Connor and John
it doesn't make sense it kind of puts a
cap on what they can make it really only
helps those lower to your guys and say
it's easy for me to say but yeah
Fighting's have a choice no one's
guaranteeing you a living the
pay-per-view the way it works is like
the champ and the whoever they're
fighting get the pay-per-view right so
people ask me all you can be on a Conner
pay-per-view you're gonna get that money
I don't get any extra if I'm on a corner
pay-per-view or any pay-per-view for
that matter unless I'm the champ right
here unless I'm the main event in the
main event so it and I in in my position
I think I'm gonna do fine I'm never
really enough to worry about
pay me more because I think I'm gonna be
able to once I'm in that main main event
spot that's where I'm gonna fight I'm
never gonna go from the main event down
to not main event right with with the
the hype that might I'm gonna bring to
these fights and I want to sell these
fights these pay-per-view say the right
it's fun as [ __ ] Chael Sonnen was the
man that Connor was the man on it and
it's it's doable so I think when I do
get no spots I think we're gonna be able
to sell good paper using specially
fighting like Cody Garber who's another
star ish like it takes two people to
build a big pay-per-view yeah and I
think I'm gonna get there and and it'll
be good the money will be good
are there guys of that are below you and
the rank and stuff that you look at and
you're like damn this guys are straight
up or anybody you're even hearing about
like this guy's a like that you know
you're like this guy's a real [ __ ]
problem yeah yeah there's definitely
guys like in the division bantamweight
division is the most stacked division in
the UFC right now I feel like from 1 to
10 it's so [ __ ] stacked well
confident I am it doesn't mean I'm gonna
I don't see them as they suck like I'm
not like this gonna be easy
right I feel like I'm gonna be able to
show up that night and outperform them
yeah like that's how I feel about
everybody but none of those guys are
easy fights at all I didn't think Eddie
was necessarily an easy fight I was just
super confident that I'm gonna show up
that night and perform better than him
so looking at the division there's a ton
of guys Mike who
that's a tough fight yeah but I'll
probably still knock him out that's
what's going through my mind you have to
think that I mean that's the only thing
you really can think is that you're
gonna win so sometimes it's like if four
people that come on you about your ego
and stuff like that or come on you would
say man he sounds really confident or
trash-talk what else I mean I guess
there's maybe ways to phrase things but
if I'm walking into a fight I'm not
thinking [ __ ] I hope we both do well a
lot of guys aren't a lot of guys you
know I feel like I built this skill set
of working my mind to thinking that way
and I don't think a lot of people can a
lot of fighters can go into fights
thinking the way I think it's a skill
that I've built up and I've practiced
about over 30 fights too and I've done a
lot of mental work you know even just
meditation and stuff like that
and and my breath work and stuff like
that I can kind of make my thoughts like
that right some fighters are in the back
you heard down adults they're only
talking about he's [ __ ] terrified you
hear Chael Sonnen saying he's not the
only one I think well I think 95% of the
guys that are going into fights are
terrified and you aren't thinking I'm
gonna [ __ ] this dude up I think I think
like that because I know how to work my
mind and know how to have those thoughts
pop up and navigate where my thoughts go
so I think it's a skill set it's
interesting you say that man yeah
because then you get into the fight and
you're like okay how am I going to it's
more like how am I going to do this then
what's going to happen right if you fall
walk into the fight like [ __ ] I don't
know what's gonna happen here that's a
different approach to something then man
I know what's gonna happen here I just
have to find exactly how I'm gonna get
it done yeah and like I said I kind of
let my boss I let go of all thought when
it comes down to how the fights gonna
play out I just trust my higher self
that I'm gonna go in
and do what I need to do but a lot of
Fighters even myself before pre like
before I even really gotten you see you
would how's the fight gonna go out oh
[ __ ]
like what if he [ __ ] drops me what
this what of that I don't let myself
even get there
Wow I'm like okay we're gonna go in
there I'm healthy I'm in shape and my
skill sets high my skill set verse Hill
skill set like for when I fight a I knew
my striking was high more high-level if
you just watch it from not thinking
about okay I'm me just watching it like
this skill verse it I'm better right and
I knew I was gonna show up so if my
skill sets better and I know I'm gonna
show up you can't beat me but there's
always that one punch and I always say
that because I know I'm not stupid I'm
still realistic there's that one shot
right he'd put your lights out but I
would not if I take myself out of it
just look at the skill set or skill set
even like if you want to use Cody for
example I feel like his skill set was my
skills that I'm better yeah he's my
strikings better and I [ __ ] show up
yeah he seems to show up sometimes shows
up emotional last fight he looked better
than he did ever and he got the job done
still he has that [ __ ] right hand
that he dips into and throws um but when
you when I take myself out of it and
look at skillset versus to go set that's
it makes it easier because I truly
believe my skill sets so high to where I
can make oh okay
if I show up I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
good so I'm not gonna overthink the
fight I'm not gonna say oh I need
hopefully this lands this lands I'm just
gonna let myself to do whatever my body
needs to do in there
do you practice uh we got a question
right here from APO it's a Big Sean
it's a shiloh out of Missoula Montana
just quick question for Sean just
wondering how does it feel to be a
fighter coming out of Helena and these
two come back here at all yeah Montana
is an interesting place you know Daniel
Cormier said it best he felt like when
he went to Great Falls which were woods
where Tim's from our from where I'm from
it feels like you're going back 20 years
in the past
Wow and it's honestly and I don't want
to say it they get had people in Montana
get mad at you it's depressing there I
don't like going back it's a weird
feeling
I think the suicide rates one of the
highest there is it's a depressing place
and I don't know what why it's beautiful
yeah it's beautiful
I've been in Deer Lodge before now
okay yeah it they got a prison there
yeah - that's where Tim's from but yeah
Montana school I'm from Helena what
there was no there's not a mall there
like growing up there was an I'm [ __ ]
mall to go to there was nowhere to go
hang out but my parents had a dope-ass
house out in the mountains like [ __ ]
right next to Lakes it was nice but I
don't go back to Montana much and I
think the best thing I ever did was move
out of Montana but I'm super grateful
that I'm from Montana because it made me
the person I am like what for whatever
reason it made me the person and gave me
that confidence being a Montana fighting
other guys from Montana beating him up
and just being in Montana I felt like
dev obviously is the reason I was the
person I was before I left but moving
out of there was the best thing yeah
most people think I'm gonna go to
Montana I probably to get my ass kicked
by some guy you thought you were like oh
I kicked everybody's ass in Montana I'm
gonna head on out but the reason I was
beating up people in Montana too is
because it was they didn't have good
training yeah heard you talk about this
that the training where you're at now
you talked about it on rogue and even
just the level of training it's like one
of the three or four hot spots that you
guys spoke about where it's just like
one of the best places to train your
penis yeah Montana was not good and when
I came down from on the reason I came to
Phoenix is because Tim was watching one
of my fights in Great Falls he was
commentating cuz he was are even
Bellator at the time and he was like hey
if you want to come down to a real gym I
see potential in you and you could so I
came down shortly after a couple weeks
after and I was 18 years old came to the
lab literally every single I was there
for 10 days every practice I left crying
a pretty shirt ham like it was bad I
realized I'm not good at fighting like
I'm athletic and I and I just don't the
skills like a people would take me down
and beat me up but you learned it and I
and I'm like but always I'm back of my
head I'm like if I can learn these
skills
I'll beat these guys but I'm more
athletic and for whatever reason I felt
like I had a pretty good IQ of fighting
and I was like I need to learn the
skills I learn skills so from when I was
19 when I moved to Phoenix still even
today I'm training pretty much twice a
day I'm still getting really good I'm
getting better in those two years that I
was out I think I improved more in those
two years than I did in the previous
four years that I was training because I
was training smarter and I'm just
training with such high level people
and retaining the knowledge and and it's
just and I've still feel like I've so
much to learn which is why I think I'm
so dangerous and it gives me that
confidence because I'm like I'm really
[ __ ] good right now but I can get I'm
just I'm just getting started
imagine in my head I'm like imagine in a
couple years if you keep training the
way you're doing it's scary to think
about my strength and strength and
conditioning Brandon Harris when he says
like we're just scratching the surface
with your [ __ ] abilities and I'm
already feeling like a [ __ ] machine
I'm like if we're just getting going and
I'm gonna be a dangerous [ __ ]
for the rest of the time I'm in the UFC
do you is there anybody when it comes to
like talking trash and like kind of you
know like you know and you have to these
days you have to be your own PR person
really I mean yeah one percent you know
uh what's that a quiet go don't get
[ __ ] that's what they used to say back
in the day you know and it's like yeah
well [ __ ] it
is there anybody we've all done some
things you know is there uh is there
anybody you you you you check in and
look at him like oh that you followed
their way of talking [ __ ] I definitely
watch I've said Chael Sonnen the number
one I think I think he was better than
calling her and I didn't get a watch it
while it's happening I better go back on
the YouTube videos click like Chael
Sonnen best trash talk and watch out
like [ __ ] I've watched every single I
watched Connors betcha and it's I watch
it like it's comedy and they're funny is
funny and that's pretty great and I feel
like I've always been you know I've
always been the goofy kid that kind of
funny guy and I'm like if I just be
myself and then learn like everything
like these guys um I think I'm gonna be
able to be pretty good at talking [ __ ]
yeah in my own way and and it's gonna be
authentic because then you
there's people can tell when you're
being real your true self and like being
funny and then people can tell when
you're being like you know Henry cejudo
who just he's with Olympic gold medalist
he's you know two-time world champ he
hasn't he's following Sox yeah he's just
not funny
and it's there's no that off stage his
personality is it is for beau
really Austin yeah and he's just so I
think but yeah chill and in Connor I
definitely watched a lot of a lot of
their interviews and probably
subconsciously learned a lot to where I
can kind of put it in my own ways yeah
it's fun man and it makes it fun dude I
love that part of it I remember after my
broke my foot I told Joe Rogan I said I
love what did I say I said I [ __ ]
love Joe but I said I love everything
about the sports the trash talk that the
build ups to the fights dude those press
conferences with that Conor have been in
with with they were so ghetto Floyd with
Floyd with with Aldo with when they're
all sitting up there he's talking about
hey dude I can't wait for those I'm
gonna give me a [ __ ] a quad shop chug
it and just get goofy on the mic and
started saying [ __ ] up [ __ ] that
people and like pushing the bound and
the funny thing is is already I want to
watch that you know I'm saying like I
want to watch it's interesting it's like
what makes people want to watch it's
that it thing but no one really kind of
knows what that it thing is but I said
up on The Contender series when I was
seven and OH or whatever I was before I
fought Alfred I said I have that it
thing I'm gonna knock out Alfred and
everyone's gonna want to watch me fight
and it just happened like that and it's
funny that was a great fight - I thought
man that was [ __ ] that was okay I was a
wild one to watch yeah it was it was
high paced and it was but I was had that
was the worst fight camp I've ever had
in my life and it was the biggest
opportunity I needed to go out there and
perform and that's what really you know
probably a lot of confidence so I'm like
I I had a bad concussion this is the
reason I don't spar too much I had a bad
concussion couple weeks before the fight
waking up in the middle of the night
puking not able to train couldn't eat
hardly so I weighed in at 136 I got in
the cage at 138 and that's [ __ ]
insane like you don't get in the you
don't weigh in at 136 getting on 138 and
I just had such a bad camp I was
completely gassed out in that fight you
can see a minute in I'm huffing and
puffing and I still dropped him so that
made me really that pride built a lot of
my just GoPro batteries getting the [ __ ]
out of me um that private gave me a lot
of confidence knowing I can still show
up when I feel like that
yeah let's look at that picture a Tim -
let's bring that back up I don't want to
that was yeah he had a cameo on uh rip
my trip who sent that in sorry we have
this boy we have this guy on a that's
been following Tim and I for a long time
names our point oh he's an OG joban of
ours and uh he sent it in like four
weeks in a row he said and he finally
got it on and it was legendary it's
funny Thea was when I had hair like you
I used to have and I had like a little
bit of frosted tips I got more puss and
I've ever got in my life oh praise God
and brother amen to that
yeah you show up looking like you can do
something and people think you can this
is when you got your first [ __ ] right
took out your shiny entender oh man
don't oh yes what's in that fanny pack
we had again hopefully more Fanny Lamar
bustles on this dude no bottoms and lube
any bro a little vibrator an idea let's
get that other question that came in
do I want to kind of hear what you guys
said about him back in a day oh yeah
let's play this yeah didn't even know
thanks God look at them [ __ ] George
Brown he kind of has that Joe Rogan of
the of the West vibe that Joe Rogan of
the future ha done me
yeah those [ __ ] bow lays it looks
like Joe Rogan if he if he was in that
movie um what's that movie were they
were those things climbing underground
and they try to pop out and see Rimmer's
tremors yeah that's old movie he looks
like Joe Rogan if he's in taxicab
confessions porn up oh yeah it looks
like Joe Rogan and Hulk oh he looks like
Hulk Hogan get his kicks know when Hulk
Hogan's son killed somebody by car yeah
man yeah I'm Nick Hogan
yeah racism he's over driving now oh
yeah you know look at the
so if somebody doesn't ejaculate under
that guy yeah we ain't this ain't
America what do you guys do whenever you
guys go out around the town man do you
guys ever go out
really we don't go out dude we train we
get high we chill that's it is it too
dangerous going out whenever you can
fight like jizzy cuz I like you know I
can do comedy so I like to go out and do
comedy you know like is it dangerous
like I might [ __ ] you up ya know I don't
look at fighting like that at all I'm
never confrontational and I don't get in
fights outside of it I know I don't I'm
never even in that situation right if we
go out it's - we'll get [ __ ] high
[ __ ] go over eat and regret it that's
pretty much like what we do
yeah we don't we did go to a comedy
place down in Phoenix I'd like to go
down there more cuz being around the
comedy club that was pretty [ __ ] fun
we never really know I only hear Rogan
talk about and you guys talk about being
on the club comedy club like damn that
sounds [ __ ] that sounds fun yeah
yeah that stand-up live Club is that the
one yeah what's it called you members in
Scottsdale
is that what it is it's a couple good
one it's not in Scottsdale some Phoenix
right is it done yeah downtown yeah yeah
stand-up live that's a good one yeah
Brendon and them were just over there
actually oh is that where they perform
yeah I think they were there actually a
good weekend last night I think or two
nights ago yeah yeah yeah
that's what they were let's get this
question in big fan of the podcast in
general all [ __ ] ten of them that you
do and just wanted to got a quick
question for Sean on that some after you
get that Bell
what are you telling Joe and now
post-fight interview what are you gonna
tell them I don't I really still don't
know what podcast is for so gangrene but
[ __ ] whatever not even sure half the
words in Louisiana said so it's limited
for a limited word ship down there yeah
after he had his buddy with him
an extra work will decide after my fight
with honor I remember saying I [ __ ]
love you Joe Rogan and then I fought
with Jose I was on ESPN that I don't
cause I freakin love you Joe Rogan and
then after that pay-per-view fo so I
think that's kind of became a thing just
a [ __ ] such a huge fan of Joe Rogan
it's [ __ ] it's so sweet that he's a
commentator there like in the UFC they
said hey how are you gonna how are you
gonna how's it gonna affect you fight
with no crowd I said Joe Rogan and is
there and Dana White say I don't give a
[ __ ] about Joe Rogan listening to him
commentate and in his podcast I'll
probably say I [ __ ] love you Joe
Rogan don't forget that though I'd be a
great t-shirt if you made that - you
mind if I use that like give me 10 bucks
little wife beater so Mike yeah he made
that Spotify money if your ex wife
beater did meter
ya future wife beater yeah you too right
the other great like a rash card cut off
what else we got Nick anything you want
to ask man this guy's go he's got a good
question okay here we go a lot of our
questions they have their shirts off I
don't know what it is but people are
fired up yeah they do it you got
push-ups
Sean what is your favorite tattoo um and
prize of price time on my face I
remember when I want to get face tattoo
Danny my girl she's like nah don't do it
and it was the star in it I said I'm
stupid enough to get a face tattoo but I
was smart enough to get a fake one first
right so I got the fake star tattoo
before my fight with Andre and it was
I'm like damn I'd like that
so so I wouldn't got the star I was
feeling like a [ __ ] superstar yeah I
was on pay-per-view I'm in the UFC is 22
years old I'm like [ __ ] I'm getting a
star on my face I ain't gonna ever work
a [ __ ] job again
so probably the star that's what started
the face tattoos and then I got and I
got sugar and then I got breathe oh it
says breathe when you look in the mirror
uh-huh that one was pretty cool because
I was going to like all that you saw the
stuff I was really learning more about
my breath and meditation and stoicism
and it all comes back to just taking
that just breathing and feeling that
breath so I got that one and I like that
one a lot
I got the heart the heart was just kind
of like I don't I just want something on
my face yeah man that's feeling hard
yeah do what you got to do yeah it's
interesting because I mean back in there
like I mean tattoos and stuff I don't
have any but it's all you know I can
stick with a little faced at tribal
thing really yeah I know but something
some small would be sick yeah I think
you gotta even if you get like a little
fake one first just to check it out yeah
you'd like it you look in the mirror you
scream I do every morning
do you yeah feel hard because you're
like [ __ ] I have to show up now that I
have face tattoos well after that and
not show up for my fight before my fight
like I got [ __ ] crazy hair I get
knocked out that's gonna be [ __ ] a
meme forever lay there my hair flopping
around yeah colorful has kind of reached
out to you know I feel like no I I'm a
huge fan of Conor obviously but I feel
like he I feel like he might be a little
bit of a drunk now yeah I'm not who
knows maybe not but I feel like he
probably looked at me like this little
[ __ ] about to steal all my shine yeah
because I'm um I heard Brendan to talk
what was it saying about the new super
the new pay-per-view model he doesn't
think anybody's gonna be like that big
superstar that Conor that Rhonda that I
think he's wrong I think I'm gonna be
the next big [ __ ] superstar but I
just have to make sure I'm continuing to
show up in the gym and get better so I
go out there and perform but if I keep
going out there and doing what I know
I'm capable of doing like a lot of
people don't think in their mind like
I'm gonna go knock this dude out in a
[ __ ] flashy way I said before that
fight I'm gonna knock this dude out in a
viral way and I did and I feel like I
can do that to everybody it doesn't
matter what style if I'm longer than you
and faster than you I can knock you out
in a crazy fashion its artistic it's
like Pablo like kick ass Oh or something
yeah exactly
cast so I might get that tide on my face
[Laughter]
column we just hired Colin maybe we'll
make him get it but no I wouldn't be so
gangster one day to have somebody who
you have to like you don't want to have
the tattoos where you make them that
would be sweet yeah that would be cool J
that's you
this is my tattoo donkey right here it
says menthol across his back tats do you
get buzz that much uh get [ __ ] up your
mating buds yeah every night not
recently I got quickly one drug that's
now call a while back but I'll probably
do it at some point just not right now
yeah I don't
what about DMT have you ever done that I
haven't but I'm definitely I definitely
like to I like how it's a quick kind of
I've been told yes you just walk through
it easier I definitely would would be
interested in doing that but uh getting
buzzed though it's so fun when you do it
but we don't do it very often couple
times a year three four maybe I drunk
yeah yeah but it like when we did buzzed
with the boys it's so much [ __ ] fun
it's just hard to like I don't want to
wake up next morning with a [ __ ]
headache yeah it was kind of become an
old-fashioned - I think like when I was
in college like everybody got drunk
right it was like how drunk can you get
Zach's dead yeah you know it'd be like
it was like oh man like who cares if
he's dead he can still drink you know it
just now you see people using more
psychedelics you see people use it more
like things that they want to have like
an actual experience yeah then they want
to just kind of pollute themselves you
know okay it's just like everything
every diet changes I think the diet of
how we get wasted
yeah is evolving as well you know [ __ ]
yeah this was kind of related this
question gang gang brother
my name is tor from Sydney Australia I
just have a question for Sean I just
wondering a few microdose anything I
don't know if you're allowed to talk
about it at all but um there are huge
benefits with it and I know that you
just saw you on drug events put costs
speaking about mushrooms so just want
any few micro dose at all thanks guys
have a good day it's cool how many
different people around the world and it
amazing they're under the podcast and
stuff like when I go on Twitch people
like hey from Germany hey from Russia
it's [ __ ] crazy thank you pretty
dude's fat it's really fascinating isn't
it it is micro dosing I feel like for me
when I use a psychedelic I feel like I
have to almost be kind of called to UM
I'm going through something any need to
figure it out lately lifespan so just
going so well right now hmm that I
haven't really felt like I needed to use
mushrooms or any psychedelics really but
I have micro dosed and it does it makes
its life more vibrant almost and if
you're in a you got to be careful if
you're in what kind of mindset you're in
but if I'm going through someone I need
to have [ __ ] figure something out
I feel like and dig deep where it's like
okay this is coming from my childhood
and this is coming from this insecurity
or you're attached to your significant
other and you get jealous in a certain
way like that's when I feel like those
mushrooms are so beneficial and so
powerful they can really help you dig
deeper into those situations and figure
out what's the next step
because mushrooms aren't gonna fix
nothing they're not you don't take
mushrooms back hello I feel better now
yeah it's gonna give you the right idea
to bake oh [ __ ] this is where I'm going
wrong this is what I need to change
right yeah yeah it helps you get out of
there some of those bad loops you can
get in exactly yeah so I think mushrooms
are so [ __ ] powerful crazy huh it's
crazy that very little Miller Lite look
like a little post exactly I think you
know Tim so it should be a national
mushroom day where everybody just kind
of trips and realizes we're all [ __ ]
one like at the end of the day we're all
one [ __ ] yeah bro everybody's
gets in a big pile in the park yeah
protest but dude how crazy do divita do
him like with your mom or something I've
always thought about that my mom's
starting to get a little weird bro I
think she was in a couple of years dude
I take a weekend off of partying and I
just go do him with my mom dude I think
that would be an emotional such a
positive thing for for me and my mom to
but my mom is so again she's religious -
where is she wouldn't do it right
because the Bible and all that but I'm
like if you'd read the Bible doesn't it
say stuff about plants and medicine and
stuff but she thinks she literally told
me the other day marijuana no twenty
cigarettes is worse than one joint on
the internet I've heard that my mom you
smoked 20 cigarettes I'll smoke a joint
let's get on the treadmill and see you
fall
let's do anything anything and uh but
she's just so cut off at that religious
block there's I just don't see her but
she used to say she's she's such a good
[ __ ] person and I love her to death
but I think she just had stuck on that
block that will marijuana so bad for you
yeah but I don't know why I'm like you
I've seen you drunk like I've seen you
drink caffeine coffees literally
opposite of weed in a sense like yeah I
don't get it has she you think she's
ever tried it I don't think she's ever
tried it no see that's the thing I think
is if getting someone and have the
experience because I think they feel
like you smoke a joint you lose your job
you get like a shitty car your air
conditioner doesn't work you cry in your
yard you know what I'm saying you
suddenly have two kids in the backyard
and the [ __ ] there's a shitty pool
that they're in like I think people
that's what people think like oh that's
happened Cosima I don't think they
realize oh it just kind of makes you a
little different you know it makes the
whole way you interact with the world it
puts a different fill yeah I think what
and I think coffee is the same thing
caffeine is a drug that makes you
[ __ ] before I had caffeine and I look
like it changes your mind it's all
mind-altering just like weed isn't let's
call it deer until a piece of [ __ ] I
don't like when littler guys talk [ __ ]
to the big UFC the big guys like I'm a
35 I'm not a big guy I'm a little guy
I'm not talking [ __ ] to these big ass
[ __ ] I'm smart enough to know
that these guys can still whip my every
night that's why I don't like when the
little guys act like they're the king of
the world even Connors like there's not
a man but that might be him playing that
up like that thing where people are
gonna wash out but it's gotten so much
easier for him to play it up it's almost
like that's become his only element
since he doesn't fight anymore yeah I
don't like it sucks because you almost
get put in this position to where it's
like for Connors like I need big [ __ ]
fights I'm not gonna fight anyone else
and he seems like like he's getting
frustrated he wants to fight but he only
has so many options right and that's the
thing with getting up in the rankings
like so your anchor 5 it's like ok I can
fight number 4 3 2 1 or the champ
but these guys are fighting each other
this guy's injured this guys [ __ ]
mom has cancer this guy you know he's
just like there's Gant you can't fight
certain time goes fast and before you
know it it's been a year it's been a
year and a half so it's like almost the
rank it's like [ __ ] once you get up
there so you can only fight a certain
amount of guy right cuz you don't want
to fight backwards it's just it doesn't
it's not it doesn't make sense but you
got to enjoy the right so you have to
plan the ride you do and I went and for
me it's like I love fighting if they get
if it was my choice I'd fight next
weekend yeah I would have had a fight
booked and we're fighting but it like I
said it's a business and I gotta do it
right
but yeah Fighting's [ __ ] and it's a
dangerous sport like I'm lucky I got out
of the last two fights no injury that's
rare yeah super rare to get out of
fights with no injuries back to back
like that have you ever fought Sammael
may as one eye or not I wanna I'm like
are somebody that only had like one
something no I remember there was this
guy that I sent the Tim they I got off
for a fight remember that yeah here's
one leg dude in Montana you can [ __ ]
fly every weekend that's the thing
that's how I used to love that sugar
used to say as a when he was amateur
he's like man I don't even give a [ __ ]
if I lose I just want to do some sweet
[ __ ] like if I can make a highlight if I
can go into a fight and get like a good
solid bunch of sweet [ __ ] like that I
did in the fight and then lose like I
always got sweet vids true bro the
highlights bro it's all MaxPreps it's
like as long as you have a couple of
good highlights right it doesn't matter
this guy's 74 hear that buddy shows up
watch him do this back think about
having being undefeated - I'm 12 I know
it's like [ __ ] that
oh is so important in the business -
it's like so I was like okay if I lose
then it's like okay now we're free to
find whoever [ __ ] it but you got to keep
that oh you got to keep the undefeated
record yeah does that did you think
about that a lot for me I think another
thing that's super that I have an
advantage of in the mental Department is
I'm not afraid to lose when I look at
losing I look at as a chance to go
through adversity a chance to be like
when I when the whole you sada thing
came about it's like that was so I felt
like I just took a li just lost like I
just got suspended for some I didn't
[ __ ] do right but I was able to
figure out
how to make it a positive thing training
wise my relationships wise just learning
a lot about myself so if I lose a fight
I'm okay now we just got some [ __ ] to
deal with mentally obviously I need to
go work on something did I get caught
that I get dropped it I lose a decision
with that I guess out what happened I
gotta go work on that and then mentally
it's like okay how do I deal with this
loss and I'm gonna be able to deal with
it because I've dealt with [ __ ] before
and I know that dealing with adversity
come out more powerful on the other side
so I'm really not scared to lose I
definitely obviously don't want any but
I gotta hope I lose next fight I'll be
sick but I'm not afraid to lose and
going into a fight if I do lose my
circle so small that I'm not gonna have
people full flailing like Kim's gonna be
there Jay's gonna be there my girl is
gonna be there my mom and dad let the
core the small group I got the guys at
the gym at TW BJJ where we trained like
those guys [ __ ] love me in there
not because I'm winning fights because
I'm they're a fan of what I do in the
and I entertain and then I go to the gym
and I'm like what's up guys like I'm so
I'm not gonna lose anybody that's
important right the only thing you're
gonna lose is just yeah just be a fight
that big deal so I think being able to
look at it with that mindset helps me go
into not be getting nervous and fights
like it's interesting man it definitely
after watching like interviews with you
and then talking with you now it
definitely gives me a more of an
understanding of what kind of your your
overall perspective of things is
definitely a little bit different that's
good yeah it's sweet being able to do
podcast like this and get asked
different questions and reach different
audiences and I have on podcasters sweet
because you you really get an
understanding of what of who someone is
for the most part you can kind of tell
if they're bullshitting or if they're
being themselves or whatever so yeah
it's [ __ ] podcasting so fun yeah yeah
it's been awesome and Nick what else we
got anything else I guess just more
specifically do you have a timeline and
when you're trying to fight again yeah
that I'm talking to UFC ITEX on Shelby
yesterday I said dude I'm ready to go in
August like I know I don't think I fight
Island sounds really cool I don't think
it does but when I [ __ ] hole would I get
there and I'm like this place [ __ ]
even if it is sweet it's like okay bean
I could either
fight the thing is - is the cage size
like the cage is what was at 44 percent
smaller almost half the size oh yeah on
fight island no no in in Vegas yeah
that's what they said right this past
weekend though that cage was smaller
yeah the one I fought in was [ __ ]
tiny and I felt it but that's when I
fought in the contender search - and
it's like for me and my advantage is my
footwork and my movement so the bigger
the cage the better for me so fight
islands can have a big cage Vegas has a
smaller cage but I would way rather
fight in Vegas but I'd rather fight in a
bigger cage so it's like okay who are we
fighting we fighting a grappler who's
gonna try to hold me down that small
cage is gonna benefit them more we
fighting a striker in a smaller cage and
still would rather have a bigger cage
but it's different it's a different game
like Eddie was a striker it wasn't it
wasn't too big of an issue um so I'd
rather fight in Vegas in a bigger cage
if I had the opportunity hopefully we're
gonna fight August a couple people like
I supposed to fight cheetah I don't know
if you know who that is yet you know his
fight was sick well he lost but it was a
I thought he won :
oh he won he lost what he wore did Louis
oh he lost he lost the decision I Vera
right there yeah yeah I thought he
wanted why do you want to that's how
crazy it let's we'll see that's what I
told do you have see two of my own I'll
fight him I know he's coming off a loss
and you're supposed to winners fight
winners UFC 31
I thought he won you know that could be
a fight to make to him yeah that'd be a
great fight might be or it gonna be
another first Raquel but no he's
definitely tough is [ __ ] he's like he's
tough he's gonna yeah and I always say
this I plan on fighting for 15 minutes
as far as when my training is concerned
like we're training to [ __ ] fight for
15 minutes most the time like throughout
my career it doesn't last like that yeah
and I don't you know when I close my
eyes and see the fight playing out I
knock him out in the first thing but
he's tough the skill sets pretty hot
pretty good he's a good grappler I think
you would try to take me down not
initially I think he's like initially
will probably like strike with then hit
him with a [ __ ] sugar smack and I can
smack him in the kids means I all kind
of grab me that's what usually happens
like against Steve
am i hitting with that [ __ ] stevia
buddy I think he called me Stevie on
Twitter did oh did he really no I didn't
he said something about make an excuse
with UFC people on Twitter so [ __ ]
stupid like it it's funny I like Twitter
now I don't use it too much I use it to
talk [ __ ] like Peter I don't know if you
saw that tweet nah didn't see peter yawn
he said uh oh yeah there's that next
time you see called donut Leif uses like
UFC called me I'm like no I can't make
it mom my grandma's couch broke and I
can't make I'm a excuse but uh I think
it What did he say he said it's my time
and I said calm down Peter or no I said
calm down you can't even spell your name
right Peter or something like that and
it's just funny little comments like
that the right there he said my time and
I said calm down you can't even spell
your name right Peter spelled it right
and uh and then he said something he
said oh yes Conan I can't phone your
name right Peter just not funny [ __ ]
like that on Twitter makes Twitter so
[ __ ] fun because it's a game well
it's interesting too for you because you
see coming out of like this twitch world
and being in like and being of a younger
generation and some guy you know like
just think it's it's more of a not real
world online yeah yeah yeah and it's
building potential big fights in the
future like that's building it up are
you're not working for me now kill a boy
yeah I don't know if he speaks English
or if he has some was translating I died
truly don't know but uh makes I'm
curious if he's actually him I don't
think he could speak that way yes he got
his own style man it's funny people
always try to jab at me from curly hair
I'm like curly hair the only we gonna
get laid yeah like you guys not an
insult
you go [ __ ] your hair but yeah well I
got laid with it so yeah it's not a good
insult I think a lot of Henry cejudo
said something out curlicue or something
did EU tip or something bout my hair my
kind of kid that's not good but it's
interesting that at where you're at you
have these guys who are taught or
communicating with you saying like yeah
it's interesting it's like the top talks
a lot of guys who could tweet it Henry's
ooh
and they're not gonna get any response
but that's not where you live right now
that's not that's not the you know the
the world you have built for yours yeah
right now and I've been I bet it is
[ __ ] exciting it's fun it's makes it
more exciting and I've been building
this up for you know I've been building
my social media up for a long time you
know ever since I guess I got it kind of
just been building up building up
building up making it like a business
yeah you know you can make like I make a
lot of [ __ ] money from my Instagram
and it's like a business there but
growing up oh if I had so many adults
tell me don't post this don't post that
you know UFC not gonna like that me
smoking weed in my [ __ ] marijuana row
listen in a 50 cent like day I wouldn't
post out us in our literally been adults
that I'm supposed to look up to it's so
hard for me to look up to most adults
I'm like your life sucks
I don't like what you tell me doesn't
really resonate you just got fired yes
yes got fired from the fire department
yeah so it's like hard for me when I was
growing up listening to the dalts like I
don't want to be like you so that's
probably not gonna not gonna listen I've
always kind of been a rebel in that way
but I've been like the social media way
post and [ __ ] that I think's funny yeah
I think it's [ __ ] funny I'm gonna
post it do undeniable that the show is
entertaining man a rebel with a cause
exactly anything else that's it for me
you got Tim man you got anything else
for this I want I want to see okay
besides Schwab and Joe Rogan I think
with your size you might be able to [ __ ]
up any other comedian
Oh what about Cal and you versed Callen
he foxes a little bit I see I think it
in a little old dog that's true I'm
actually gonna stop by Tony Jeffrey's
gym on the way home he's got that box
and burn hits emits or what yeah I'm
just gonna check it out I'm gonna get a
membership over there anytime I want to
I need to fight somebody I think you
word Brian sparring three threes would
be [ __ ] epic I'd watch that I'd be in
it I mean yeah your size and intimidated
me I don't think people know yeah you're
taller you're like I can get it man I'm
already
we got a mullet so you can get yeah I'll
get [ __ ] your head yeah [ __ ] yeah
already John a little if you could jab
Brian cuz I haven't met Brian either so
I don't know he's small he's small I was
quick in his hip so he's got this kinda
I guess that he's got that wiggle in him
yeah
but he's very small he's almost like he
is the physique of like Elf on a shelf
member alpha on a show ya know Elf on a
shelf
I can see bright yeah okay yes small
physique almost like somebody said him
somewhere up on the Shelf with trap so
he does have nice yeah but his muscle
his bone densities going down somewhat
even in the past year yeah yeah he's
heaven where do you think you'll be like
tactical or morally unjust emotions like
I'd go in mouth first yeah I do all many
people [ __ ] yeah get emotional Oh
someone slap you in the rap this
squealing with a five my finishing move
is I can hold him down damn and I cry
straight into his mouth drown him bro
[ __ ] I think it's some crazy finishing
moves bro dude I have some I really do
like we got things that have never been
done you know I do that I do I have
moves that have never been that people
are gonna be like I think I'm not real
yeah that's the goal people I get in
fights people a was that meal I want to
be a that big of a character and we got
the moves I have this the techniques
down like this guy's using are three
isn't it yeah yeah they're gonna be very
interesting what is a UFC gaming gonna
be able to keep up with the [ __ ] that I
actually can do so it's gonna be sweet
I'm excited it's nice to be healthy
right I really feel healthy because with
that strength and conditioning program
I'm doing I'm doing that and building
that dense bones and I just eating
healthy so I my body's so and when I'm
healthy and athletic like this I'm a
dangerous [ __ ] and I have so
many sweet movies to finish people with
and you gotta remember I'm almost I'm
511 and most the guys in my division or
five seven five six like little dudes ya
know you that link that almost makes me
when I'm watching you it makes me
nervous yeah for some reason cuz I'm
like oh because the visual is that oh
this guy looks you know like the who was
the good gentleman whose stamen stamin
no Cody stamen yeah yeah
when you look at him you're like Jesus
Christ but so he's closer to five foot
than his Wow you know what I mean so
does that scare you though when you see
somebody with that body like that
physique the skin it's just like I mean
if you know it's funny funny than it is
when you see a [ __ ] you get scared
without a [ __ ] he's 5/3 not really
that's true man you're right it's not
scary no no when they're jacked like
that it's like okay he's gonna try to
take me down and hold me it's not scary
thinking like that because I got to get
inside
gotta get need elbow kick steeped
there's a lot of weapons a lot of a lot
like it's dangerous coming in to my
range a lot of blades a lot of blades a
lot of blade just got with ya Sean
O'Malley the show thanks man yeah that
was [ __ ] awesome thanks for coming in
bro exciting man Tim thank you so much
[ __ ] yeah good to meet you guys yeah and
of jxj x-rays as you come Jesus Jesus
and he does look good social media
stuffy
yep Jesus does our podcast vlogs runs
our patreon for the most part like
posting on stuff so agenda yeah dude
having that stuff going is so huge bro
[ __ ] yeah a lot of people don't have
that so thinking ahead like that bro
we're on top of it we got the squad on
top of every deer that's huge
[Music]
but when I reach that round I'll share
this piece of my background I can feel
it in my bones but it's gonna take
little time for me to set that parking
brake and let myself all my
[Music]
[Music]